[Música]
i
hola que tal buenas noches
bueno hoy voy a tratar un tema que
seguramente les preocupa bastantes de
ustedes me gustaría saber
quien tiene garantizada especialmente
los padres pensando en sus hijos quien
está garantizado el futuro de sus hijos
en relación a la tenencia de una
vivienda la posesión de una vivienda a
poder comprar una vivienda al girar la
qué tema no están un poquito caros
los inmuebles los alquileres
y no es una cosa menor
y este tema
que llame el mercado inmobiliario el
futuro de los chicos
nos afecta a todos en realidad grandes y
chicos lo que ocurre es que yo voy a
hacer el planteo de un tema voy a hacer
una propuesta de una posible solución
pero claro implementar la mañana es una
utopía
no se trata de una solución mágica sino
una solución que requiere
requiere de la conciencia colectiva de
que todos seamos conscientes de cuál es
la problemática y cómo se puede llegar a
solucionar
por eso digo el mercado inmobiliario y
el futuro de los chicos
porque ellos
podrían llegar a tener la oportunidad de
no tener que vivir las mismas
situaciones que viven mucha gente que no
puede ser propietaria y que además tiene
que verse
invirtiendo mes a mes un gran porcentaje
de su sueldo en alquileres sobre precios
inflados
ustedes no sé si recuerdan los más
grandes seguramente
hace escasos 25 o 30 años acá nomás en
la ciudad de esquel
una persona que contaba con dos mil o
tres mil dólares podía comprarse un
lindo terrenito y bastante cerca del
centro
les repito las cifras dos mil o tres mil
dólares
es mucha plata
pero no es inalcanzable si un trabajador
pudiese ahorrar
ahora esos mismos terrenos cuestan 10 o
20 veces más si tenemos acá terrenos a
cannes que el de 30 40 50 60 y para
arriba este siguen los precios no tienen
límites y tampoco tienen lógica
y ese es el lado oscuro del mercado
inmobiliario que no se maneja con
ninguna lógica más que la lógica de la
especulación y esa lógica de la
especulación es la que nos afecta a
todos nosotros nacemos en un país que
como todo país tiene una superficie
más o menos no recuerdo bien el dato
pero la superficie continental de
argentina es de unos 3 millones de
kilómetros cuadrados
como vemos en el cuadro inferior a la
derecha
ahí vemos el crecimiento poblacional de
la argentina en los últimos 60 años
en ese periodo de tiempo
la argentina sobre duplicó la cantidad
de población la pasó el doble cd más del
tiene más del doble de población
sin embargo lógico la superficie
argentina sigue siendo la misma
y el terreno
en su mayoría estas manos privadas que
pasa entonces con todas estas nuevas
generaciones que van naciendo
en una superficie determinada donde está
el espacio para ellos
y si esos espacios son privados
y sus precios son sobre evaluados a que
estamos sometiendo a nuestros chicos
recordemos
que la casa la vivienda el hogar es una
de las necesidades básicas que todo ser
humano tiene que tener satisfechas
no es una cosa menor necesitamos agua
comida y vivienda una persona sin
refugio es una persona que no puede
desarrollarse es una persona que ha
comprometido su futuro que está
condenado a estar de alguna manera atado
durante décadas de su vida al
endeudamiento con un banco
o con una empresa que alquila
y esto en algún momento tiene que tener
un giro un giro que beneficia a todos no
a una minería
a que había algo que yo llamo la teoría
del acaparamiento
cuándo
el espacio se vuelve cada vez más
reducido
hay empresas poderosas
que manejan en cierto modo el mercado
inmobiliario
acaparan con su poder económico grandes
extensiones de tierra o grandes
cantidades de propiedades
y es falta de oferta
y habiendo una gran demanda los precios
aumentan exponencialmente en definitiva
grandes capitales terminan viviendo del
trabajador de esa persona que tiene que
salir a trabajar todos los días y que un
gran porcentaje de su sueldo termina o
en un crédito hipotecario a 30 40 50
años o en alquileres eternos sin poder
ni siquiera poder clavar un clavo en una
pared propia
qué opciones tienen entonces las
personas para acceder a una vivienda
para acceder a un hogar a este refugio
qué se necesita para crecer para
constituir una familia o simplemente si
no se quiere tener hijos para poder
vivir desarrollarse en forma individual
tenemos básicamente tres formas por
herencia que los padres de alguna
persona este
en donde no le dejen en herencia los
bienes que ellos posee los bienes
inmuebles que ellos poseen las otras
opciones son el alquiler o la compra a
través de un crédito de estos créditos
externos que terminamos pagándole a
grandes bancos
y qué consecuencias trae en estas cosas
a la vida de las personas principalmente
la vida endeudada eternamente endeudada
y eso con el estrés que genera tengo que
pagar el alquiler no sé si voy a llegar
no me aumentaron peor aquel que pierde
el empleo y que no sabe dónde queda
parado y cómo va a ser para afrontar el
próximo pago o ese crédito con ese banco
peor los que agarran los créditos suba
ahora que no saben cuánto terminan
pagando
es una locura cómo está organizado el
sistema
y otra de otras consecuencias porque
para pagar ese alquiler ese crédito
tengo que trabajar más y ese tiempo que
trabajo más es tiempo que yo se lo ruego
a mis hijos a mi familia
y qué más necesita esta sociedad que
padres que puedan estar más tiempo con
sus hijos o no cuantos problemas
sociales vemos porque los padres se ven
obligados a tener que trabajar tiempo
extra para poder cubrir las necesidades
básicas entre ellas la vivienda
y es así como
esta situación se transforma en un gran
problema social que todos lo tenemos a
la vista
el problema es que nos acostumbramos a
esta especie de status quo de las cosas
donde las cosas están así y son así
y no nos planteamos en algún momento
cambiar y de eso se trata esto por eso
les decía al principio que esto es una
charla con una solución utópica para hoy
porque lo que les vengo a proponer es
una posible solución quizás que haya
otras quizás que haya más
pero si empezamos a sembrar esta idea de
que esta situación es injusta que es una
necesidad básica y que el estado tiene
que intervenir porque para qué está el
estado si no es para regular la relación
entre las personas
entonces acá lo más importante es
deconstruir toda esta estructura que
tenemos nosotros
en función de cómo funciona la sociedad
y cómo está organizada
romper ese status quo es decir me voy a
dar la posibilidad de pensar de que hay
otras soluciones porque en la argentina
tenemos soluciones para cada uno de los
problemas el tema es que nadie las
aplica
vivimos en un país inmenso inmenso y hay
problemas habitacionales es una locura
lo que creo firmemente es que hay que
regular este mercado inmobiliario
para que de una vez por todas se den
soluciones a esta problemática y hay una
forma bastante sencilla entre comillas
de regular lo que es basar los precios
de los alquileres
y de los precios de la venta de los
inmuebles en el valor fiscal de ellos
claro el valor fiscal lo usan todos para
comprar vender un inmueble y pagar menos
impuestos nunca se declara el valor real
en una transacción de compraventa
pero eso sí para fijar los precios de
alquileres o de venta los inflamos
exponencialmente y ahí es donde tiene
que intervenir el estado
tiene que dejar de ser
un elemento de lucro sin regulación
los inmuebles tienen que dejar de ser
elementos de lucro sin regulación
si nosotros podemos limitar la
rentabilidad porque que ha pasado a lo
largo de los años en nuestro país con
las variables económicas que sobre el
dólar que baja al dólar que los
inmuebles están dolarizados y no sabemos
qué hacer que tenemos unos pesos
ahorrados pero sabemos que la
devaluación va a ser que no tengamos
nada mañana y la gente empezó en vente a
invertir en ladrillos y grandes
corporaciones también
pero qué significa invertir en ladrillos
y buenos conservo la plata y tengo y
acaparó y bueno y ganó plata sentado en
el escritorio que está haciendo que otro
que tiene menos recursos económicos este
me pague a mí por el simple por este
simple el privilegio de poder tener una
posición económica más fuerte y ahí
tiene que intervenir el estado para
regular para que no pasen cosas como
comodoro rivadavia por ejemplo vayan a
pagar un alquiler a en comodoro
rivadavia porque las empresas petroleras
acaparan casi todos los alquileres
sale muchísimo como pasó acá en el año
2003 cuando por suerte se fue rápido a
la minera de acuerdo en el tema de la
minera cuando empezaron a alquilar
algunos inmuebles y los precios de los
inmuebles este se hicieron impagables
acá mismo en esquel
por cierto por suerte se fueron rápido
esos efectos se mantuvieron
relativamente en el tiempo pero después
bajaron un poco cuando nosotros
convertimos al mercado inmobiliario en
un mercado no tan rentable no digo que
no se gane plata pero que no sea tan
brillantemente rentable como lo es ahora
cuando lo convertimos le ponemos una
regulación el propietario de ese capital
se va a ver obligado a invertir en otras
cosas porque eso no le va a dar tanta
ganancia y en qué va a invertir o
invertir en producción en comercio en
industria se va a ver obligado a mover
una gran masa millonaria de millones y
millones de pesos y de dólares que
anualmente se pierden en un mercado que
no tiene sentido que no produce nada que
genera malestar en la gente si todo ese
capital se viera obligado a invertirse
en una producción en diferentes
producciones y la que decida cada
propietario de su patrimonio cambiaría
toda la realidad de la argentina porque
habría millones de ofertas laborales
pero además si ese inmueble ya no me es
rentable porque yo lo compre para para
sacar un lucro lo voy a poner a venta
porque parece que lo quiero
y así se ponen a la venta un montón de
inmuebles y al haber demasiada oferta
empiezan a bajar los precios de los
inmuebles naturalmente
básicamente lo que les quiero transmitir
es esto
como les dije antes soluciones para los
problemas hay
todos tenemos que ser conscientes de que
la única manera de que las cosas cambien
es empezando a transmitir estas ideas
empezando a ser conscientes empezando a
participar y empezando a exigir de que
tengamos un país para todos
y no para una clase de poderosa
muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]